Where is your proof that $150 million
was offered from BB and Yahoo? No, I'm
referring.
>> Where is the proof? Please do not get
it. No, no, no. Because I didn't want to
cover this and you guys insisted and I
told you if you cover the I'm going to
rip you apart. This is not for me. I'm
not interested in this. I love you guys.
I know.
>> I am a rever and I was taught how to
pray salah. That means every single time
I pray,
>> the person who told me gets the reward
>> five times a day from fud to is
>> if you want to support someone like me
in learning salah
>> then sponsor 10 people for just 100 this
Ramadan. Remember the prophet peace be
upon him said charity does not decrease
wealth. Click the button and donate now.
Brother sisters, it is getting sweeter
and sweeter. Oh, all the the um the
satisfaction of watching them in
fighting showing the satisfaction of the
whole world waking up to this reality of
Zionism and how evil they are and how
they are behind every single evil.
Here's a video of Ana Casperian and she
is talking to this pro-Zionist Julian
woman and she rips her hair out. She
goes absolutely crazy. But before that,
for those who don't know Ana Caspian,
I'm sure you do, but this is how
heartfelt her messages. This is just the
video. Let's just watch for ourel how
she deals with a Zionist dirtback who's
trying to justify the connection.
>> He's saying he's being criticized for
giving an audience to people like Dave
Smith. He's not saying that he is
changing his mind and thinks the Jews
are evil. Like he chang
>> and I want to be deadly accurate if
we're going to have this conversation.
So that's what he was talking about.
It's about the fact that Dave Smith, he
gave him an audience at Turning Point
and he was being criticized for having
people who didn't agree like Tucker on
the stage. wouldn't say my mind here and
I'm being attacked.
>> So basically he's getting this pressure
from donors which led to that meeting in
the Hamptons with Bill Aman because Bill
Aman apparently wasn't happy with it
either. But you guys also have to
understand that there is um a trend now
with young conservatives who are not
supportive of Israel or not as
supportive as previous generations.
>> That is just one part. It's going to get
worse, guys. She's going to lose her
mind slowly. You're going to see it.
Look how she's talking about. Okay, the
context. know Kirk didn't to change his
tune to Israel, you know, he just uh the
ones who were funding him, the
lobbyists, uh you know, those who were
the funders, the private funders who
were funding him, um were upset that he
had um Joseph um Dave Smith, Dave Smith
on there. Okay, that's freedom of
speech. Why are you upset about it? Now,
she proves further the claim that oh,
you know, the issue was just they're
just upset. Why are they upset for if
it's freedom of speech and they can talk
quite why can't you criticize Israel?
Why can't you? Here's the next clip,
guys. Watch how it escalates slowly. She
starts she actually goes mental and this
shows you what kind of this this is how
these people are. They don't deal with
Christian. They talk about oh Islam you
know we can't criticize everything but
Islam bull crap. It's a lie. It's the
biggest lie that they ever live.
>> Where is your proof that $150 million
was offered from BB Netanyahu?
>> No. I'm referring
>> where is No, no, no. Because I didn't
want to cover this and you guys insisted
and I told you that cover I'm going to
rip you apart.
>> Whoa. Rip you apart? Bloody hell. Yes.
This is what you following the IDF. you
know, they're ripping children apart
with their bullets and their bombs. And
um she's she's look at the look at the
phraseology she's using, the
terminology. I'll rip you apart. Look
how angry she is. Why is so angry? This
lady on the left is basically saying
there are speculations that Benjamin
Setanyahu offered him 150 million. He's
not saying she's not saying that's a
fact. They're discussing the topic. Look
how she goes crazy. Why are you going
crazy for what happened to freedom of
speech? Huh? Why the freedom of speech?
Oh, does it only work when it's against
Muslims? Oh, I thought so. Yes.
>> Where is the proof? We're not saying
Netanyahu
$150 million. We're not so on is in the
marketplace. What they're saying, this
is a discussion that's happening
literally everywhere. We would be
remissed if we didn't cover it.
>> This conversation over
it's a week old. She's basically saying
let it bury. It's a week old. Why are
you bringing it back up? Why resurrect?
It's dead. It's a week a week old. A
week old. You Zionist, you talk about
so-called attacks that Muslims don't
etc. You talk about it day in day out.
Yeah. Most of them most likely you guys
Israel are behind it. Yes. Okay. With
your force flag attacks. Look how it's a
week. People just upset that you're
bringing up what happened to freedom of
speech, man. Why are you so agitated?
Let's go
>> is a week old.
>> It's still going on. Jillian, I I
>> Okay. Well, nevertheless, where is the
proof that that actually happened?
>> I just said according to this guy's
reporting,
>> he was offered 150 million.
>> Candace, it was by Candace. And not only
that, by and listen, I like Candace. She
has people from Oh,
>> you do not like Candace, Julian. You do
not like Candace.
>> His own team have said he has not seen
her in years and yet lost together,
>> which is a lie. Uh Candace actually
debunked that. Oh, they haven't seen
each other for years, which is an
absolute nonsense. Rubbish.
>> There are two things being conflated
right now. There are conspiracy
theorists who think Israel killed
Charlie Kirk. They have yet to provide a
shred of evidence proving that.
>> Get the hell out of it. It's an open
secret. Come on, Anna. You know very
well. Okay, I know you're being a bit
wary here, but you know very well they
were behind. Who benefited from it? Who
benefited from the death of Jico? Who
who if you want to find the corporate
who benefited from it? They done it
directly or indirectly.
>> Done. End. We're not talking about that.
I am talking about something entirely
different. No, hold on. Let me finish my
thought. Okay. The real issue here is
that before most people even knew that
Charlie Kirk was dead. You have
Netanyahu giving multiple interviews
talking about how oh using the moment
for his own political purposes.
>> Exactly. Exactly. You know, not only is
most like it shows that he was behind
it. Not only that, why are you even
using that as a propaganda tool of using
the a dead man's um a his death to prop
for propaganda reading part of the
letter he sent you
>> like the
finish point him killing Charlie Ker
>> I did I not just I literally
>> did she just not say which I disagree
with that there Israel did not do that
>> let me finish my point Jillian because
none of us can finish the damn point
without someone else jumping down your
throat
>> I don't think that Israel killed him
because there's no evidence of that but
>> get out of here please
>> I had a problem with Netanyahu
exploiting an assassination in this
country for his own political means and
purposes and lying about the nature of
his relationship with Charlie Kirk.
>> Okay, good. So, now here comes the
Zionist freedom speech that they love
and you know Benjamin the Satan uh was
saying basically, you know, Charlie Kirk
stood up for freedom. Well, let's see
the freedom speech of those other
co-hosts said and we just mentioned some
rumors that's going around, etc.,
whatever it is, etc. And look how she
reacted.
>> She could have had a conversation about
it, but that's not what happened. This
is what happened
>> cuz Charlie Kirk didn't like Netanyahu
just like any warm-blooded American
shouldn't. Netanyahu is a bad guy. And
he wanted to make it seem like, "No, we
were all great. We were good. We had a
great relationship." Little did we know
behind the scenes there was
talking about how do we bash Israel?
>> Bash how do we bash Israel? Look how
agitated they are. And this is actual
truth. If there's anything that people
should talk about is a genocide, a
massacre that's happening. What do you
mean? Oh, people. It's like it's like
you have a serial killer who kills
people. We all know it and we're we're
condemning him as why are we always
talking about the serial killer, man.
Why does everything have to be at my
brother who's a serial killer, man?
Because he's killing people. No, why is
what the flipping are you talking? How
about your brother stops killing people
and we stop talking about him? Hello.
No. Look, look how she goes mental.
That's freedom of speech. Don't forget
they love their freedom of speech. Yeah,
I'm sure they do.
>> This is not for me. I'm not interested
in this. I'm sorry.
>> Let's be good. Let's be good. Precious
is real. I don't think myself or those
ladies like you. So, bye-bye, you dirt
bag. The
>> country committing a genocide. Okay.
Zero. I think you guys are great. I
fundamentally disagree with you about
like I showed you on this. I'm sorry.
>> Cool. So, can we continue the
conversation?
>> Let's not. Let's
>> Okay.
>> Oh, I love that. I love what Anna did
that Anna Casper. Yes. Let's just carry
the conversation. The barking dog has
gone now. Let's carry the conversation.
Fantastic.
>> You wanted to do it anyway.
>> Let's finish the last topic.
>> All right.
>> Wow. Okay, guys. So again, to clarify, I
don't think Israel did it.
>> Oh, whatever, man. Why do you need to
clarify? Why do you need to clarify?
Everybody knows. Everybody knows they
have the capability. They They're the
ones that carry the most assassination
around the world. Yes. Okay. And they
have the means. I'm
>> sorry. It is not some angelic country.
It's a foreign country. And we have the
right to be as critical of a foreign
country as we want. We have the right to
be as critical of our own country as we
want.
>> Thank you very much, guys. There you go.
Subhan Allah. Brothers and sisters, wah,
like I said to you before, we ask Allahh
to guide these individuals who are being
dr. Allah has put mercy in everybody's
hearts that Allah guides them and you
know like as I mentioned about
anakasperian etc. Allah says in the
Quran like you know we ask Allahh guide
Allah says in the Quran in chapter 10:44
indeed Allah does not wrong people in
the least but it is people who wrong
themselves okay subhan Allah and also
Allah says in the Quran and the record
of these will be laid upon laid open for
the disbelievers and you will see the
wicked in fear of what is written in it
they will cry and say woe to us. What
kind of a record is this that it does
not it does not leave any sin sin small
or large unlisted. They will find
whatever they did present before them
and your lord will never will never
wrong anybody. Subhan Allah. Allah
saying when the disbelievers are given
their books they will say what kind of a
book is this? It's written down anything
that is small or big. They're amazed.
Imagine you have a book which tells you
the the temperature, the time, the
location, the exact movement of the sin
that you committed. It's scary. Why am I
mentioning this guys? Because Ana
Casperian is an atheist who denies God,
you know, and but we ask Allah subhanaa
tala to guide her because we can see
goodness in her. But best believe Allah
never wrongs anyone because Allah will
give her reward in this life if she dies
as a disbeliever. If she knows Islam is
the truth, by the way, if she doesn't,
that's a different story. We know
they'll be tested on because Allah is
fair, you know, and Allah will never
wrong anyone and Allah will reward the
disbelievers because Allah's just in
this life. They will get that. But there
will be no portion of the hereafter. We
ask Allahh to guide people like her
because you can see that the mercy that
she has. Subhan Allah.
Subhan Allah. It's crazy that as as as
an atheist herself, she has more mercy
than these Zionists or whoever they
actually believe in God that they don't.
Brother and sisters, that's what I want
to share with you guys. Inshallah, it
was a pleasure watching this Julian
ripping her hair out and walking out
just because people are mentioning a few
speculations or rumors, et behind it.
Till next time, brother and sisters,
if you enjoy this video, share with your
friends and family. And my daughter is
there with a little headphones. We're
going to go home. Goodbye.